you give me data i give you art
it's a rather a facetious statement but
i'm rather a facetious speaker in the
middle of pie data
so just roll with it for now um firstly
i apologize for my strangely odd
appearance um
i fell off my bike two weeks ago in
brighton
and smashed my head along the asphalt
and was knocked out for half an hour
which has broken my brain and my
eyeballs a little bit so just bear with
me if i get it random during this talk
i'm an artist who works in a number of
different media
um painting here this is from a series
called
corporate fight club about businessman
fighting
make installation digital art
and various other things that kind of
bridge the digital and physical world
and i'm going to talk to you about four
of those today
firstly for the record i am an ex-geek
i'm a survivor of the dot-com boom of
the late 90s and early 90s when the
whole world looked like this
uh i also have a phd in cognitive
psychology
um back in the damages and past and i
was also briefly very famous
in america for about a year that's me
and hugh hefner
but today we're going to talk about
materials
so let's start with what a material
means to an artist
here's a cave painting our hominid
forebears would find
a nice red colored rock that stimulated
their visual field they'd grind it up
they'd make it into a pigment through
the process of art they would make
marks on the wall this is the dawn of
art and this is what art feels like for
most people they pick up a paintbrush or
they
manipulate physical objects to make a
sculpture
these days it's not really like that art
can be a lot of other things
and one of the materials that i'm
interested in working with
is data which is why i'm at the pi data
conference
the task of the art is to take the
material and transform it and that's
what artistic practice is so i'm going
to talk about four things
that deal with data
so um this is my first bold statement of
the day
um when we're talking about the
algorithmic universe i'm talking about
basically the stuff that involves
computers and people where data is
created
destroyed manipulated reinterpreted and
presented to people
that's that's the algorithmic universe
and data is the stuff that it's made of
or it's an important material in there
i think the interesting bit is where the
humans
meet the algorithms or whether humans
meet the data
but using algorithms to process your
material is not new
um this is
this is the work of william latham some
of you may have heard of um
he went on to produce uh very
complicated digital
three-dimensional objects in the early
nineties
a big fan of brining and all that sort
of scene but what we see here is he's
got
a rule or an algorithm which he's using
to develop his art so if we look at this
one here he's starting with a nice
little
cone like triangle and evolving out
along these paths into more complex
forms
and that was the kind of the beginning
of his practice as an artist
um what i find interesting and why we've
got a commonality with pi data is
what he's done here is evolved out his
forms
till they reach a certain degree of
complexity where they're kind of
visually exciting
and interesting um whereas
most of the big data stuff that you guys
are into is taking data that humans
can't comprehend
and bring them down to forms that humans
can understand so there's a commonality
here there's a kind of pleasingness
about how you've summarized your data or
where you've taken your practice
it's kind of a sweet spot for humans and
i think that's kind of where
where i'm talking about algorithmic art
it's kind of what where it's all about
it's like what can you make that humans
like
let me see i'm missing there we go right
this is my meta slide because we're
going to talk about big data
big data is data that humans find too
big
to handle all right so they get very
excited about it i assume because it's
big
and it's beyond their heads um it's not
a term i have
much love for i must say big data i
think it covers
a multitude of sins but it covers the
kind of stuff that i'm dealing with
which is this
relationship between the raw data the
machines that make it
the algorithms that we write to process
it and the humans who then consume the
outputs
of this processing technique it's kind
of like a it's kind of like a
artistic practice so you know give
yourselves a slap on the back for being
artists
um
yeah so for shorthand we're going to
call this stuff data
and we're not going to worry about
whether it's big or small and i'm going
to tease apart what i mean by data and
how it can be different stuff in a
second
so the four projects i'm talking about
are based on the big data that people
are giving away
mainly because they want artists and
geeks to do the work for free
but that's my cynical view i'm going to
look at redacted data
where people publish data and then
change their minds
i'm going to look at my data the stuff
that i spit out on social media
randomly over time um and
our data in terms of the nature of
surveillance and
what it is how it feels that your data
starting getting trolled and analyzed
by machines and systems that we don't
necessarily have control or
understanding of so let's start with
number one
the tate gallery here in london
very kindly released data on
all 70 000 artworks in their collection
um it's got the usual stuff who painted
it what it's made out of how big it is
who bought it when they acquired it
but it's also got a bunch of interesting
data that can only have been created by
humans
um the example here
would be uh this one there's a there's a
tag called emotions and human qualities
apply to all the artwork
and it's got things like this in it
right so this artwork contains
shock and complacency
and frustration these are very
interesting data points for an artist
because they're human right this is
human stuff this is not a log file
that's come out of a
file server somewhere a humans actually
had to look at this piece of artwork
and tag it in this way and when i
chatted them about it after this project
they told me that this is down to humans
actually sitting down and looking at
every single artwork and classifying it
and showing it to someone else and
making sure they all agree
and then producing this metadata around
the artworks
so it's brilliant it's unlike any other
kind of big data that i've seen
mostly it's just it's big there's lots
of it go do something nice
whereas this is created by humans so
it's got interesting uh
interesting features to it um here's a
couple of the categories
um drilling down so universal concepts
include power and evolution and good and
evil and
futility um there's a mythological
cluster here about whether
you know which kind of mythological
entities they are and they're related to
the
personifications and that kind of thing
so there's a really interesting
stuff around each of these artworks but
the data itself is cast about the
artwork so you say here's your painting
it's created by x here are its tags so
the first thing i did was turn that on
its head
and use that data as a way of navigating
their collection
so you can go in and say look find me
anything that features a dustbin lid
is this example because that's a feature
that's in the domestic space
of interiors and lo and behold there's
stuff in the collection that's to do
with
um to do with dustbin lids and this is
true all over the shop and it's uh
it's interesting because it's a
different way of coming across the art
normally if you go to the tape you
wander around and there's a series
of paintings that have been chosen a
small subset of the 70
000 artworks that they have and you see
them in the order they're presented to
you or you
look at the big one first because you
you know can't see very well whereas
this way you can actually get to all
this data
from a different way you know it's
literally a different way of slicing up
and um while doing this
the insight that i had is that these
descriptors
are descriptors of data points
in the data space seventy thousand of
them but in fact they describe
the world of art to tate as far as the
people of detail concerned
this is enough for me to classify
everything we have
and what you've got is lots and lots of
tags
lots and lots of potential certain items
tick off certain tags but some of them
don't
and it reminded me of this guy
anna moore who has the uh the
the idea of idea space and as a
creative thinker what you're doing is
stepping out into idea space and finding
it like a discoverer like you know
someone on a c-pairing yacht discovers a
new land ah it's here it's mine
i've defined it i've created it and
that's what he's talking about when he
talks about idea space
and so what we've got in this tape data
is an enormous idea space
there's a whole bunch of ways of
describing things that have fallen out
of this process of describing the
artworks that they had
um so i built a machine that does that
um
here's an example so
this is a description of a non-existent
artwork
created from the way the tape describes
other artworks
you've got the materials it's made out
of there's aesthetic qualities subject
matter symbolism
and what you can do is create these kind
of complex and pleasing
descriptions of artworks as an artist
that's really exciting
i'd really like to see something made
out of marble dolomite stone and vehicle
doors that's already an exciting thing
and look it's got a symbolic moon of the
virgin mary
and a snow drop of consolation and a
hair of emotion
right surely that is a work of art i'd
love to see
um and because of the wonders of the
computational explosion um there are 88
million
of them so there are 88
million possible artworks based on the
structure of the
data that's already a fascinating thing
they gave me 70 000 artworks i gave them
88 million back
you know what can they ask for um it
also produced my favorite ever comment
which was this one on boing boing which
is every
living human got busy dashing off one of
these artworks an hour
we would be done only two by 10 to the
power 18 years unfortunately
if the works averaged a kilogram they
would not only produce a crushing force
of gravity but would
actually begin fusion before they were
done this is a difficult project
that would can't really argue with that
um right so that's that's public data
that was given away
um specifically with this purpose and it
was interesting going to meet the tate
afterwards because i was one of the
first people to do anything with it and
i was like
brilliant you did something with our
data it took us years to make that data
and we really wanted someone to do
something with it and they're very
excited that people look at it in a new
way right and i think that's a lot of
the story about
big data and handing it out to artists
and other developers
is please do something with this
i'm sure there's something in there but
we run out of ideas can can you do it
and can you do it for nothing please
anyway that's uh that's that big data
now we're going to look at uh redacted
data
um this is
a phrase that everyone's familiar with
and it forced me to go and find out who
actually spat it out and apparently
it was a stuart brand
in the 1960s who was the actual founder
of the whole earth catalogue
so if you know your geek history that's
like the original internet in book form
and the problem it gets to is the
information once you've published it in
a digital form
doesn't want to be deleted it's really
really hard to get rid of your data once
you've put it out there
in fact it's a kind of known problem in
data science it's like don't publish it
until you're really sure
which leads me to this guy right
uh as you may have heard at the end of
last year
um the conservative party deleted
all of david cameron's speeches in fact
it deleted all of the conservative party
speeches prior to that year
so what was previously said by our
current prime minister about what he was
going to do
and how he's going to make everything
better for us conveniently disappeared
off the internet and to the point where
they
they edited the robots.txt and say look
don't even look here anymore this is
like somebody else's problem field built
into it
um now whether this is kind of
intentional revisionism
because they're evil and want to change
the world or whether it was just some
housekeeping
bug with the website we don't really
know but the fact was
they deleted them and there was a big
stink about it
now thanks to archive.org
there's historical snapshots of the
conservative website and so actually
it's relatively easy to go and find them
if you want to find them
so i hoovered them all up and had a look
and see what he'd said
and this is the first result of it
um uh i thought what did he promise
what did they promise that they actually
did or didn't deliver on
and this is just a simple like find me
every sentence that starts with we will
and order them for me give me the first
punch and it's actually a beautiful
piece of poetry when you look at it
we will continue our ruthless pursuit of
tax evasion you know they did that
um we will reform the nhs they also did
that right so some of it's true
but what came about was this feeling of
kind of terrifying beauty
that by looking at these words that
normally i wouldn't you know give a crap
about
conservative party speeches but actually
looking at them in this way
there's something quite fascinating
about the structure and the form of
writing a political speech it's much
more like poetry
than it is about fact giving the better
you say it
the more compelling the way you describe
the world
the more believable you are it doesn't
really matter if you're telling a pack
of lies or whatever
so i built a machine that writes poetry
based on
uh the speeches of david cameron called
algo cameron and it's still running now
and i
i didn't even do the calculation on this
one but i imagine it's equally billions
of billions of possibilities
that it creates and i guess i mean aside
from just being a bit of a dick
it was uh it's fascinating that you you
know
proving that point that if you publish
something
and you publish it digitally it's never
going to go away
right there's no no way that you can
expect to change your mind about that
decision
and i think that has an important effect
on anyone who's publishing data
you know it may be sitting on a server
that
you only know the ip address of but it's
public because you haven't got around to
locking it down
expect it to be found expect it to be
copied expected to be crawled
expected to be indexed don't ever think
that your
your data is safe and this is actually
known as the streisand effect
uh named after barbara streisand who in
2003
uh tried to suppress the publication
of photos of a mansion so someone had
got in
taken pictures of her malibu beach house
tried to get them the pressure oh
that's terrible it's an invasion of my
privacy whatever you do don't do that
and lo and behold it was a huge story
right it's known as the stars and effect
that's exactly what cameron has done
by quietly trying to sweep his data
under the carpet
he only draw attention to it right
so bear that in mind if you publish
publish and be damned or publish and
don't be damned i guess
all right third project this is based on
my data
shard echo is a twitter bot
based on me recently
twitter allowed you to download the
history of your
activities on their social network and
they give you a nice
big fat csv file i think of everything
you said
and my feeling about social data is
on the one hand it feels very ephemeral
that you can
write something a status update and
forget about it
but it's not to see cameron's point
earlier once you've written it
and you've put it public it's there
somewhere and it's a problem that i
discussed with my teenage daughter it's
like you're 14 what you right now is
still going to be available when you're
28 or when you're 58
it's not going to go away so i kind of
wanted to look at that what does this
data tell
the world about me what is in there you
know i have however witty i think i'm
being in my 140 characters i'm
bleeding out something about my
personality so the first thing is this
kind of just gross chart
i had to have a chart it's pi data um
it's the chart of
how i tweet based on the three years of
tweets i call that
i'm quite quite busy on fridays
mid-morning
because i can't be asked to do any work
so i send more tweets that already is a
kind of insight into the way
i'm behaving with social media and in
fact um
people are horribly predictable there
was a study in 2010
based on phone location data
that found your location in an hour's
time
is predictable with a 93 accuracy based
solely on your mobile phone date
and the fact that people behave the same
way all the time so 93 of the time i can
guess where you're going to be
without even knowing anything about you
so short echo is a bit like me it's
based on my
tweets uh but what i did is went in and
used
actually this is python so that's right
i used some python to
extract the um adjectives and nouns that
i'd used
and create a dictionary of things that i
talk about
and the way in which i talk about them
and then it relives my life
so at the same time on the same day
three years later
it finds that tweet that i sent out it
takes it and says okay
if i throw out the adjectives and i
throw out the hands and pick some random
ones
and put them back in then i'm going to
make
a more or less linguistically valid
tweet
most of it's nonsense but you know
occasionally it comes out with real gold
and it's a it's a it's a kind of
it's a fascinating way of looking at
yourself right
it can only ever say what i've said
using words that i've said it's not like
a dictionary of everything it's only my
words only the words that i've chosen
to put out on twitter um and it does it
so i've got three years of my life
on twitter recorded which means it
actually tweets three times as often as
me
so at this point in time whatever it is
five to three
on the 22nd of february last year if i'd
sent a tweet well now shard echo is
going to do it i'm going to do it again
so this is the kind of uh the time
course of my social media is still there
but the actual content is you know
interestingly messed with
um one of the things it does is it will
answer you
as well so it's not quite just a dumb
robot
if you talk to it send it an app message
it will scan for keywords and see if
i've responded to anyone else in the
past
using those keywords and then it will go
through this process again and take my
response to someone else
and rewrite it so it's more or less
talking about what you're talking about
um i mean it's obviously a bit crappy
it's like being impersonated by someone
with a neurogenerative disease basically
but it touches on something quite
interesting because this notion of a
um a distributed self or
um a kind of ai entity that's human-like
is something that's quite popular you
know my phone has siri on it right i can
talk to that and it will talk to me
i'm kind of happy with that interaction
i don't use it very much
however if that robot really sounded
like me because it watched everything i
said
then i could get it to do tasks for me
right so when my mum emails me and says
the internet's gone down how do i fix
the
i could get my little robot to answer
that question for me
that's brilliant right but already
that's much more useful than siri
and i'm comfortable with that but then
what what if i got that robot and said
look
will you break up with my girlfriend for
me anyway did that that
feels like qualitatively different right
that feels like the sort of thing you
wouldn't want a machine to do
but if you spent you know 90 of your
time
flopping off your mum's emails to a
machine maybe you'd also follow your
relationships with you i don't know
um so yeah what this notion of what it
is that
is essentially about you and getting a
machine to try and imitate is something
that's in the post for all of us right
it's going to happen it's not just going
to be the series of this world that you
talk to it's going to be a version of
yourself
is the most compelling one so you know
it's worth having a look at that
um i guess the point of this is this is
mined
entirely on what i've publicly said so
this is the bit that i've
consciously given out to the world and
i'm kind of aware of my deal with
twitter when i do that
when i post it it goes on their server
forever and
someone can search it i've never met
it's going to be there i kind of get
that right
which leads me to this fourth quadrant
of data
um uh which is
the kind of data that we're bleeding out
that we don't really think about
um now i've classed them into beline and
milligan
um people will disagree very strongly
about my
definitions of what's going on in
england but bear with me for a moment
there's the kind of stuff that amazon's
doing you know you like x so you're
probably like why
or facebook you're talking about buying
a new dress you're probably single
right or google which is just scanning
everything that we do
absolutely in every possible permutation
just so
maybe it can sell us a few more pairs of
flip-flops or something
but it doesn't feel that bad it's doing
it we don't mind i kind of see how it
works
the algorithm is somewhat transparent to
me
um and then
we got the malignant ones right the ones
that we don't like
like prism and tempura
or you know gchq putting putting devices
right here right into the transatlantic
pipe
watching our data go in and out the
country
what if it's some 10 petabytes a second
or something some incredible figure
which thanks to edward snowden we know
about now
but it for most people it feels a bit
uncomfortable
people don't like being watched um my
favorite
uh question on this subject or quote on
the subject is
if you don't worry about privacy
why do you have curtains in your house
just think about that for a second
anyway
the implications of this system is much
bigger if amazon recommends me a bad
product i'm not going to buy it
if prism decides i'm a terrorist it's
going to affect my rights
you know they might lock me up they
might stop me from traveling they may
monitor me more
yadda yadda but i don't know anything
about that
but i actually feel that they're kind of
the same kind of stuff and we're just
looking at it in different ways
so when this occurred i found myself
running a digital art show
and being somewhat contrary i put a
painting a digital art show
so this is william hague um checking
your emails
outside mi6 on his smartphone
um he's surrounded by seven magpies uh
because of the sort of people that steal
shiny objects like your data
seven magpies from the the uh kids rhyme
one for sorrow two drawing three for
girls seven for a secret never to be
told
um the interesting thing about this
particular painting
aside from its subject matter and the
looming black clouds
is it's got a raspberry pi built in it
which looks at you through his left eye
so anyone who actually looks at this
painting gets recorded
it's running some python face
recognition stuff that i downloaded
and uh once it's snatched when it's kind
of grabbed your face
it then transmits it to a digital nest
that is built elsewhere the little
peppers go so you can see yourself
being sent out of this machine and i
think
part of what's fascinating about it is
looking at a painting
is one of the most intimate things you
do it's just you
and a work of art and looking at it and
trying to decide how that makes you feel
what it represents all that kind of
stuff
you feel like you're totally alone it's
like ah this is just me
and this piece of art so actually going
in there
and stealing someone's uh impression i
felt was a pretty good metaphor for
what's going on
um so i've got a little clip here oh i
don't know if you can hear it
probably not gonna say much you can see
what it's uh
how it works
so then gets transmitted over to this
nest here which has got a pepper's ghost
inside it
so you can see yourself in a couple of
seconds actually being stolen by the
painting
um and the key point i guess is this is
exactly like
the data sharing relationship that the
nsa have with
gchq so it means
uh the nsa aren't allowed
to look at american citizens and gchq
aren't allowed to look at your uk
citizens but they have a data sharing
agreement which means oh i can call up
the nsa
and find out about uk citizen and vice
versa so it's total [ __ ] right
anyway we can talk about that one later
uh
my conclusions i'm gonna be quick so i'm
running out of time uh i've shown you
four different projects here
relating to humans and this algorithmic
universe and with data because this is a
conference about data
and so what is our relationship to big
data and the big machines that are
computing all this stuff for us
i guess the message i'm trying to get
across is that being a data manipulator
is a moral position you can't be
agnostic about it
because what happens is you take a lot
of data that only a machine can handle
and you summarize it in either a nice
pretty graph
or some headline numbers whatever it is
you're
compressing it down and you'll make
those compression that algorithm is
making a decision a kind of a moral
decision how this number
ends up has ramifications
you know we can look at the gaussian
coupler equation used
across the board in high finance
in the mid 2000s that was used to
compile the risk on a
basket of products to create a
derivative product
and this equation was great because it
gives you one number about oh
this thing has got a 54 risk
all right i'm going to buy it i'm going
to sell it to him i'm going to sell it
to him i'm going to sell it to him and
there was a caveat in this equation
which is
this all works so long as the underlying
price goes up
but everyone ignored that they went ah
there's a brilliant summary
this thing summarizes and simplifies the
world for me
i'm going to use it um so i guess my
take-home point
is uh never underestimate the stupidity
of your audience
so you have a moral responsibility when
you're manipulating data
because someone a pointy headed boss is
going to look at it
and make decisions that perhaps not the
ones you intended
so be careful out there all right
that's it thank you very much
well i think algorithmically they're
very similar
but the result of amazon
and uh facebook's algorithms you can see
right i can see in some way what it's
done oh that ads changed
you know this this ad means that i'm
more interested in buying a new car
because it's been what you want to do i
can kind of get a feeling for it whereas
the
the stuff that i'm calling malignant
here i mean i think they're both
malignant but the stuff that's really
malignant is the stuff that you don't
know about
where decisions are made about your
future and you as an individual and the
judgment about you
that you don't have no access to right
i don't know what amazon is quite doing
but i know um
what amazon's i think i know what
amazon's business model is they want to
sell me more crap right
so when they try and sell me more crap i
you know the fact that it recommends
stuff that my friends like
why not that's probably how i do it
kieran isn't the part of google's
business model to sell you
so the more complex the profile they can
get of you
the more sales worthy that is and even
if we reach a point in time where
corporations and governments become
pretty much
you know interchangeable which some
people say it's not
so dystopian then surely at that point
that that separation has been aligned
with english
yeah i mean i as i said before i think
that the distinction between
yeah the distinction is kind of
arbitrary it's just a convenient
shorthand for
this discussion but i think google is a
very interesting case in point
that google knows probably a lot more
about me than the nsa does
just from my google search history and
there's a lot more about me
and if you think of someone like
facebook who are
aside from their 19 billion acquisitions
are somewhat on the back foot
as a veteran of com 1.0
i know full well they're going to die
sooner or later and someone's going to
come along in a fire sale
and buy that data set someone say oh
facebook i remember them haven't they
got the
information on 10 billion people oh yeah
it's worth
half a million and i'll buy it and
they'll do
you know however you think facebook are
being responsible and nice to you
and helpful the next guy who gets is
going to be a hell of a lot worse
so once again it goes back to this point
about redacting your data is that once
you've given it out there
it's out there and just because the
current user of your data is being nice
doesn't mean the next one will be
any more for any more i fight back by
painting pictures of it and sharing
about it and people at pie data
conferences but um
i guess
have a responsibility to know where your
data bleed out points are
i got very paranoid about gmail reading
all my mails so i
ran my mail server now i get 10 times as
much spam
it's awful but i've got away from google
and it feels like
you know technologies that allow people
to escape from data bleed are important
encryption is incredibly important but
dull and hard
and so not really widely adopted if
anyone can think of a way of making
encryption sexy and easy then you make
yourselves a lot of money
oh man
yes for my sins i was briefly very
famous in america for about a year
due to appearing on a television program
which i'm not going to go into now you
can ask me later at the drinks
but part of the uh the perks was being
invited to the playboy mansion
and being filmed um
and i could say the playboy mansion is
one of the most hateful places on earth
i've ever been they may have this
beautiful grotto that you can swim under
but it's so chlorinated it makes you
feel a bit dirty about
what's going on in here and why they put
so much going on
so yeah we can discuss that over a drink
okay
thank you